game of thrones prequel series house of
the dragon is coming in 2022
it's based on georgia or martin's book
fire and blood vol 1.
and on martin's yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
firing blood covers the tales from the
legendary egg on the conqueror
all the way up to the civil war the
dance of the dragons that nearly tore
their dynasty apart
while fire and blood vol 2 will continue
from their part 1 ended
and will cover blackfyre rebellions and
go all the way to the mad king and
robert's rebellion
that ended targaryen dynasty house of
the dragon is based on the targaryen
history and therefore it's not
surprising that this show will feature
many targaryen dragons
and the most powerful of them all
balerion the black dread
balerion called the black dread was a
dragon of house targaryen
he was ridden by king aegon the first
targaryen during his conquest
alongside his sister queen with xenia's
vegar
and his sister queen rhaenys's marxist
other known writers of valerian were
king maegor the first targaryen
princess aeria targaryen and king
viserys the first targaryen
valerian died of old age in 94 ac
during the reign of king jaehaerys the
first targaryen being around 200 years
old
valyrian scales and wings were black his
fire was black sometimes with swirls of
red
when he was in the fullness of his power
his flames could melt steel and stone
and fused sand into glass balerion was
named after the ancient god of the
valyrian freehold
he was born in valyria and was one of
the five dragons
aener targaryen brought with him when he
fled to dragonstone to survive the doom
of valeria
after the other four of aener's dragons
died valerian became the last creature
to have seen the valyrian freehold in
its prime
valerian was the largest of all
targaryen dragons since sagon's conquest
his wingspan was so large that his
shadow could engulf entire towns when he
passed overhead
his teeth were as long as swords and his
jaws were large enough to swallow a
norix hole
or even one of the hairy mammoths that
are said to roam the cold wastes
beyond the port of eben by 93 ac
valerian had finally stopped growing he
had grown sluggish and heavy and was
difficult to rouse
when prince cesaris targaryen claimed
the dragon that year
the dragons struggled to take to the air
but back to prime valerian
valerian was claimed by aegon targaryen
some time before he married his sisters
visenya and rhaenys
aegon became involved in wars in the
disputed lands
when pantos said tyrosh approached him
inviting him to join a grand alliance
against volentis
and he chose to heed their coal mounting
valerian
he flew east to meet the prince of
panthos and the magisters of the free
city
then flew to lease in time to set ablaze
a valentine fleet
trying to take the city afterwards aegon
turned his attention to conquering the
seven kingdoms
during which he flew on valerian aegon
then began planning the invasion of
esros
long before launching the attack
spending time incognito
on valerian in air scouting westeros
visiting westerosi's cities and castles
and gaining intelligence on the
different houses
their lords and their vessels aegon
historicists arrives and their three
dragons led a scanned few thousand
troops in invading the entire continent
of westeros
aegon descended on lords mootoon and
darklin killing both of them during
aegon's first test
next aegon took valerian to harrenhal
where king kar and hoar took refuge in
his formidable fortress when horror had
not yielded by sunset
he took valerian high up and descended
inside the castle walls
and put the castle to flame valerian's
dragonfire burned so hot
that the towers of caron hall went up
like candles
melting and twisting into the shapes
they retained to this day
king heron and his son's soul perished
ending the line of house
despite being vastly outnumbered aegon
was able to secure victory after victory
using valerian
aegon next rode valerian in the field of
fire beside his sister sun vegard and
maxis
vegard was a she-dragon of house
targaryen and like valerian she was also
named for one of the gods of old valeria
vegard was large enough that one could
ride a horse down her gullet
but not as large as valerian nor as
strong
it's also said that vegard's breath was
so hot that it could melt the knight's
armor and cook him inside
but not as hot as valerians which could
melt steel and stone
marxists like vegard was also a
she-dragon of house targaryen
and like two of her siblings she was
also named for one of the gods of old
valyria
myrix's was larger than vegar but
smaller than valerian
marxists could swallow horses whole
between the three dragons four thousand
men were burned to death
including king mirn the ninth gardener
resulting in targaryen victory
aegon's army was defeated but the
targaryen dragons valyrian miraculous
and vegar allowed aegon to achieve a
great victory at the field of fire
which resulted in the death of mern the
ninth gardener
and the surrender of florian the first
lannister when aegon learned that king
tauren starkid crossed the neck and was
leading army into the riverlands
he raised the head of his army on
valerian to meet the threat
when the targaryen host was encamped at
one side of the trident
and the northern host on the other side
dorian's brother brandon snow
offered to assassinate the sleeping
dragons
recalling the destruction the three
dragons had caused on field of fire
thoren instead submitted to aegon
according to a song
at the end of the war valyrian helped to
forge the iron throne by melting the
swords of fagon's fallen enemies
aegon treated the defeated lords with
respect and allowed each region to
retain its own laws and customs
aegon often traveled with valerian
throughout the realm with maesters who
educated him on each region's local
customs and history
aegon later flew valerian into battle
during the first dornish war
where he suffered the greatest loss when
his sister queen reigns targaryen and
her dragon marxist fell from the sky
after a shot from a scorpion took the
dragon in the eye
the war took a different turn after this
aegon's fury and grief at the loss of
his wife was such that he headed for
dorne himself
accompanied by visenya the last two
targaryens rained fire upon the desert
strongholds
to break the dornish the next two years
were known as the dragon's wrath
a period when every dornish castle felt
the fury of the dragon riders
the only castle spared was sunspear the
seat of house martell
in hopes that the dornish would turn
against their liege lords
the strategy failed and dorne remained
unconquered
after aegon's death valerian was claimed
by his son prince maegor
who had long coveted his father's mount
and had not claimed another dragon
because he considered all others
unworthy after jonos aaron imprisoned
his brother lord ronal
and declared himself independent of the
armed round
maegor rode the black dread to the whale
and put down his rebellion
when maegor was exiled to pentos as a
punishment for his polygamous marriage
he took valerian with him after his
brother king aeneas the first died
maegor flew back to westeros on valerian
to claim the iron throne
in his reign as a king maegor used
valerian in the burning of the sept of
remembrance
and did many other battles against the
faith militant
in the battle beneath the god's eye
maegor used valyrian to kill his nephew
prince aegon
and his drag on quicksilver after
maegor's death
valerian returned to dragonstone where
he made his lair
valerian was claimed as a mount by
princess aria targaryen
in late 54 ac they disappeared and went
missing for more than a year
king johar is the first targaryen sent
expeditions to try and locate valerian
and the young princess and the master of
coin regular dress offered a reward for
any information on their new whereabouts
but none came forward that were credible
valerian was the largest living dragon
in the world
but there were no sightings of the
dragon anywhere
septum barth believed that the lack of
sightings suggested that valerian was no
longer in westeros
valerian returned to king's landing in
56 ac
descending into the courtyard of the red
keeper area barely clinging to him
the princess was severely ill and died
soon after
bart's accounts described wounds and
half-healed scars on valerian
the dragon bore a huge jagged rant down
his left side
almost nine feet long and fresh blood
still dripped from the wound
hot and smoking bart speculated that
when arya claimed valerian
she was unable to bend the dragon to her
will and instead
the dragon had taken her to the place he
had been born valyria
what could cause such wounds to mighty
valerian remains unknown
shortly thereafter valyrian became the
first dragon to be housed in the dragon
pit
where he was guarded by the dragon
keepers valerian remained at the dragon
pit
memphis says alissa targaryen came to
the dragonpit
to claim a dragon of her own in 75 ac
the dragon keepers persuaded her not to
try and claim valerian
insisting that the dragon had become old
and slow suggesting that she would much
more prefer
a faster dragon the last writer of
valerian was prince viserys targaryen
who entered the dragon pit to claim the
dragon in 93 ac
valerian was hard to rouse and struggled
when viserys
urged him into the sky they flew around
king's landing three times
although his heirs later confided to his
father that he had originally intended
to fly valerian to dragonstone
however fearing that the dragon lacked
the strength to do so
viserys adopted otherwise valerian died
in 94 ac
less than a year after viserys claimed
him as his mount
along with 18 other targaryen dragon
skulls
valerian skull hung on the wall in the
red keeps throne room
after robert's rebellion king robert the
first baratheon had the skulls removed
from the throne room
and stored them in a dark cellar that's
the story of the mightiest targaryen
dragon
he's seen it all and been through it all
from the valyrian freehold in its prime
to conquering the seven kingdoms and
living to see generations of targaryens
rule in westeros
valerian was the largest dragon ever
seen in maestros
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace
you